I didn't know what a good time to talk
about this was on the episode but I
wanted to bring this up I should hope I
should have maybe opened with it but
it's a little bit more of a serious
thing and a somber thing and a sad thing
yeah but it means a lot to us comics
here Mitzi shore passed away and Mitzi
shore passed away and it was a it was a
weird thing it was first of all it's a
sad thing because she owned the comedy
store and she created the comedy store
and you know for 46 years ago and it was
a it's it was and is the greatest place
for us as comedians to feel at home and
to you know she always made it a point
to where you could say whatever you want
to onstage and not be judged and I
always felt that at the Comedy Store and
I don't feel that at all the other clubs
I mean I I make myself feel that way
when I'm doing the road and stuff like
that but at the Comedy Store it felt
like you were accepted for that for
being unapologetic in your stances and
in your comedy and they wanted that they
wanted you as an artist to be that way
and I learned a lot at the Comedy Store
because of that through Mitzi and
through the people who ran the club that
were employed by Mitzi and I met her at
least once and she was just like this
this
of all she did so much for comedy but
she was like this woman that that cared
about it so much and like I always say
here if you know you listen to this this
podcast you know I love when people are
good and care about what they do but she
loved finding talent and like nurturing
comedians and loved trying to spot
talent and you know she she told people
what she thought of them and she made
careers made comedy career she made
stand-up careers
happen and she was one of the people
that started something I can't I'm
paraphrasing this but I was reading the
other day about how she kind of like
helped birth Comedy Central in a way or
what has come to be known as Comedy
Central but without her comedy would be
a different thing
stand-up would be a different thing
today she's just like a legend in comedy
and I don't know if people who listen to
this podcast know that I know some of
you do because your comedy fans
obviously you listen to this podcast but
but people think of comedians as the
people that change the game for comedy
and oh yeah Richard Pryor and George
Carlin and whoever Eddie Murphy and you
know the guys now that are moving comedy
in the direction that it's moving but
but there's also the people that aren't
on stage that do that like Mitzi shore
and and I know others too but Mitzi
shore was arguably the most important
person who did who was that and she she
passed away a few days ago
and you know I knew her I met her like I
said once or twice she passed me I was
one of the last I was one of the last
people that I was actually the laughs
the last person that she passed I
believe I was the last person that she
passed at The Comedy Store that where
there were showcases I know she I know
she passed one other person after me but
just because she came to the club and
saw him on stage and was like put that
person on the right on the lineup a lot
and that was just in Martindale who's
great but she just hadn't like she would
do that she would just happy she would
just see somebody and be like put that
person on every single night at 10
o'clock and whoever was running the club
would be like really and and that person
would then become you know a big comedic
star and because she felt like oh she
would do stuff like
that this person needs to open the show
at nine o'clock every night for a year
because she thought that that person
needed that in their journey or whatever
you want to call it or you got to give
this person late-night spots they got to
go on at 1:00 a.m. because they need to
talk to five people and become more
conversational or whatever she would say
and she had ideas for every comedian and
she was like oh you know they said they
said they called or like the godmother
at the Comedy Store and I just look The
Comedy Store is my favorite place period
and it's my favorite building and I love
performing there and she made it that
way
and she meant a lot to me and I you know
I she meant a lot to a lot of comedians
and I you know I think she knew that but
it was just it was just her not and even
though she wouldn't come to the club a
lot anymore because you know in her last
days last few years she's really fragile
in' and old and but it was still a weird
moment for me I can speak for me even
though I didn't have many moments with
her at all but just knowing that she had
had passed on and it it made me feel sad
and it made me feel I mean I'm still
figuring it out you know but I sit and I
think about it and the Comedy Store and
and and just what she's done and how
crazy it is that one person can do so
much and my heart goes out to the shores
and pauly because she's Pauly Shores mom
I don't know if people know everybody
knows that but you know I fortunately so
far don't know what that feels like yet
to lose a parent but that's that's uh
it's got to be the worst so my heart
goes out to Pauly I think he's dealing
with a well I mean I haven't
talk to him yet but you know he seems to
be active and being sweet on Twitter to
everybody who's talking about it and but
we all we all as comedians loved loved
what she did and even the people that
didn't know her are like thankful about
her it's just it's just really cool it's
cool that there's somebody like that and
that comedians can can have their moment
where besides the fact that they're
always making fun everything to just
like you know be serious about something
and and and and express to people how
how much she meant anyway I'm kind of
going on a lot about this but I just
wanted I wanted to because she was a
really important person in comedy and
she's and because of that she was really
important person to me and she she
passed me at the club and that meant I
mean that's one of the things in
comedy that like comedians would start
to be like I want to Mitzi sure will she
see me I mean was she passed me do you
think she thinks I'm good enough and and
that's just that's just cool cool to me
that that I don't know I appreciate that
moment that that that small moment that
she gave me in my life and made me feel
accepted and I don't know it's just a
awesome thing and so rest in
peace or whatever they say you know to
to Mitzi shore and thanks for what you
did in comedy